so who's more likely to you going to
choose between shalow and shador who's
more likely to have better bars shador
makes songs every day that's the funny
thing shador has my studio equipment
right now who's more likely to get on
the Au honestly it just depends who
carard is to be real shalow plays like
young people M like just little viby
songs shalow is a different type of guy
it'll be like a peer born who's more
likely to get yelled at by coach Prime
shall every who's more likely to get a
spontaneous tattoo shador just got
actually I'm the most likely to get a
spontaneous that too but shadora more
likely to win at Uno that's like stuff
we play kids these days they don't play
stuff like that they'll play ping pong
sh and my dad are the goats at ping pong
sh went to take classes cuz he's like
bro I'm about to just be the greatest
pingpong player ever